for four weeks America engulfed in
protests every day all over the US even
as the country faces the continued
threat of a deadly pandemic sparked by
his death they chanted his name and it
morphed into a movement calling for
police reforms sometimes it was violent
but mostly it was peaceful we asked
people to describe what America is now
feeling what is the mood in America
right now what would you say it is I
think people are tired I think people
are fed up I think people want change
and I think people are willing to do
whatever it takes to get there it's a
lot of hurt it's a lot of pain it's
people who have just felt that for so
long we've been pleading about police
brutality systemic racism it's
heartbreaking but I think that there's
also a tremendous sense of inspiration
and hope and empowerment by the fact
that everyone is coming together in this
beautiful unified way on Friday millions
of people in America are expected to
celebrate what's called Juneteenth an
unofficial holiday commemorating the end
of slavery in the United States this
year in the wake of the nationwide
protests there is a growing number of
calls to make it an official federal
holiday just here in New York on Friday
there are more than 20 different
protests that are planned for Juneteenth
as people see it as a great opportunity
to take to the streets to continue to
let their message be heard in a country
where moods have encompassed anger to
fear to hope in an exhausting yet
unforgettable four weeks in American
history
Gabe Rose Ando al Jazeera New York